it  should be  yeah it's also pretty good well it's  incredible with rapport that he's the  most entertaining player i think by  clear clearly  i don't know i'm quite entertained by  napoli karwana  and fabi as well but i know what you  mean he has a very  unique style  yeah i mean it's maybe it's the the most  unexpected things are happening in his  games now of course the napo also had  many interesting games  fabio  he's pushing it like i know how many  tries  anyone would need to guess to move b3  here  no seriously if you give this position  to a grandmaster what's the first  five moves i guess h3 bishop e3 knight  d5 maybe knight a4 maybe a4 a3 b2 knight  b2 king h1 i21  all of these i would guess before b3  for sure yeah h4